well Las Vegas man returns from his trip
to find his apartment completely
ransacked by what he says are squatters
yeah in a quick second he came face to
face with one of them and it turned
violent Victoria Saha joins us near
Arville and West Flamingo with more
Jermaine Prickett says he walked into
the unthinkable almost every single item
he owned was gone and then the squatters
returned but this time one left with a
gunshot wound
this is what Jermaine Pritchett walked
into after being away from home for a
couple of months pretty much took
everything his apartment destroyed it
pulled things apart they cut the bottom
of the couches for the sake of his
privacy and safety we aren't disclosing
exactly which apartment complex he lives
in how do they get in I bet I still
don't know Richard says squatters took
everything from Electronics to linen to
clothing to socks and just as he was on
the phone with 9-1-1 Pritchett says one
of the squatters came in not sure what
was going to happen Pritchett grabbed
his gun shooting the person once and I
was scared to death if you know I I
heard the noise because you know nobody
comes to my place without an invite you
just go into people's places so what if
it's open is this
Pritchett shows the aftermath the
squatter bleeding and denying breaking
in look what they did to my place when
you're in that kind of a situation you
know that it's life or death police
showed up and took the squatter to the
hospital in their notes they classified
this as a self-defense it didn't just
stop there Pritchett says the next night
he caught someone else trying to break
in I grabbed his his arm as he was
reaching in I held him this incident has
caused Pritchett to be stripped of his
sense of security and safety I
definitely feel 100 violent Pritchard
said he had to plead with his apartment
complex numerous times to change his
locks and then they finally did I also
called the complex to see what more they
could do to prevent this from happening
again they did not want to comment
Victoria Saha 8 News Now
well Victoria also reached out to Metro
Police they say this incident is still
under investigation now they couldn't
say whether that person who was shot is
out of the hospital yet but said the
suspect was cited and the second person
you saw was arrested by police now they
also say if you are ever in a situation
it is best to call 9-1-1 but it is up to
you to decide what the best thing for
you is and of course your safety